vier jahre lang sollen russische
sportler bei weltmeisterschaften beim
olympischen spielen nun als neutrale
athleten antreten und nicht unter der
russischen flagge das hat die wada hier
in lusan heute entschieden auf ihrer
exekutivsitzung einstimmig wie es heißt
und sofern sich die russische anti
doping agentur die damit gleichzeitig
wieder suspendiert wurde diesen
beschluss fügt wird es wohl so kommen
dann würden sowohl in tokio wie auch bei
den olympischen winterspielen den
nächsten in peking 2022 russische
athleten nur als neutraler athleten
starten und nur unter der voraussetzung
dass sie belegen können nicht von den
manipulationen von dem staatlichen
doping-system in russland in den
vergangenen jahren profitiert zu haben
tatsächlich aber kann man zweifel haben
ob es so kommt denn dass die usa dagegen
diese entscheidung keinen widerspruch
einlegt das kann man sich kaum
vorstellen angesichts der äußerungen die
aus der russischen politik kommen denn
für die insbesondere für die russische
politik ist diese entscheidung hier aus
lausanne natürlich ein schlag ins kontor
man kann sagen das was in russland in
den vergangenen acht bis zehn jahren als
russische sport dekade landes bringen
sollte und auch glanz gebracht haben bei
den olympischen winterspielen in sotschi
bei der fußball-weltmeisterschaft 2018
in russland das liegt nun in trümmern
denn der ruf ist komplett ruiniert nach
wie vor gelten die russen im
internationalen sport als betrüger die
betrügereien die tricksereien die
manipulationen sollen sich davon ist die
wada exekutive nun überzeugt bis in den
januar 2009 10 fortgesetzt haben im
anti-doping-labor in moskau dort sollen
daten gefälscht und manipuliert worden
sein
dieses labor war damals und der
beschlagnahme des staatlichen
ermittlungskomitees das und der kreml
verwaltung steht also insofern eingriff
des staates dort weil dieser
manipulation wer genau es war scheint
bis heute unklar
gleichwohl unter dem strich bleibt da
die reputation russlands als sportnation
und wenn man nun wird allerdings
interessant sein zu sehen inwieweit die
internationalen fachverbände die
gegebenenfalls hier auch noch ein
widerspruchsrecht gegen die entscheidung
der wada haben auf der linie der wada
liegen denn sie könnten auch vor dem
casting auch vor das internationale
sport schiedsgericht ziehen um gegen
diese entscheidung dass beispielsweise
in russland keine weltmeisterschaften
ausgetragen werden sollen in den
nächsten vier jahren um gegen diese
entscheidung vorzugehen man wird sehen
ob sie das tun oder ob sie sich dem
entscheid der wada fügen insofern ist
das alles schon auch jedenfalls auf den
ersten blick ein bisschen
widersprüchlich und da sind noch etliche
details zu klären
sofern diese sanktionen dann von sport
zu sport umgesetzt werden sollen und in
den einzelnen verbänden ist der
russische einfluss auch unterschiedlich
groß insofern konnte sehr sehr viel
arbeit auf die sportverbände zu in der
kommenden zeit sofern der usada diese
entscheidung akzeptiert noch einmal sie
hat nun 21 tage zeit dagegen in revision
in widerspruch einzulegen dann würde der
internationale sportschiedsgerichtshof
cas entscheiden